für euch jetzt anfangen mit dem video
wollen noch schnell sagen das ist jetzt
so eine info die ihr gleich
wahrscheinlich verstehen werdet ich habe
jetzt wirklich mein abi fast hinter mir
und jetzt kommt wirklich aber ich
versuche es halt fast täglich im video
rauszuhauen
deswegen schaltet immer ein am tag oder
guckt mal nach abends ob ich neues video
herausgebracht habe oder nicht wirklich
freuen
jetzt viel spaß mit diesem video und wie
gesagt schreibt eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare ich hoffe ihr versteht mich
bis heute was glaubt jetzt bekommen bei
neuen video
ich bin gerade hier unten mal wie das
ist im moment ein uhr 3 und ich habe
morgen keine schule weil ich musste
eigentlich prüfung mehr ich habe jetzt
noch ein abi prüfung und kann morgen
eigentlich ausschlafen dann wird die
prüfung ist donnerstag ich bin zwar ein
bisschen müde kann aber irgendwie
überhaupt nicht schlafen deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht komm mach es einfach
noch mal ein video bzw halt jetzt
einfach im video
pascal bock zu und ja ich hab mir früher
wäre ich gerne mal videos zu ernsteren
themen gemacht das habe ich aber
irgendwie in letzter zeit nicht mehr so
stark gemacht warum auch immer keine
ahnung es hat mir eigentlich ein
bisschen spaß bereitet so sag ich mal
ein preis spaß bereitet aber ich finde
es auch mal wichtig so über ernstere
dinge zu reden klar
vieles geht euch gar nichts an aber ich
habe mir so gedacht york kommen
teilst du doch einfach mal so einen
gedanken den ich so hab wirklich gar
nicht täglich habe aber schon so
wöchentlich klar für viele von euch
jetzt vor allem auch die jüngeren
zuschauer ich habe wirklich
wahrscheinlich sowieso was so jung der
hat 200 keine ahnung dass das jetzt
vielleicht schon aber das ist doch
bestimmt ein geiles leben wenn man halt
abonnenten auf youtube hat und dann kann
man so viel erleben und bla bla bla es
ist auch alles mega cool und ich bin
super froh dass es so ist jetzt niemals
gedacht diese 270.000 passiert ist es
eine heftige zahlt nämlich eine krasse
zahl die hätte ich wirklich für niemals
für möglichkeiten so da hatte ich 2000
abonnenten und war so der jahrgang 2000
das ist da heftig krasse hunderttausende
einfach für mich so unerreichbar
wirklich unerreicht ich weiß nicht aber
immer als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
ich stell dir vor du als 100.000
abonnenten 100000 das werde ich niemals
schaffen so und wenn nicht schaffe dann
neuerlich alter ohne scheiß ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich das wirklich sorgt die
kette kriege euch das
zu übermitteln was ich so wirklich denke
und was mich wirklich so ein bisher
mitnimmt so allerdings jetzt enthält
270.000 und das ist gleich muss das
erstmal vorweg sagen es soll jetzt auch
nicht falsch bekommen und ich bin auch
ich habe überhaupt keinen plan wie
dieses video bei euch ankommt ob er mich
verstehen könnt oder ob ihr sagt egal
was laberst du dein leben
du musst auch fröhlich mal lieber oder
so könnt ihr mir mal nach dem video in
die kommentare schreiben wenn es halt
bis zu einer gruppe was mich sehr freuen
würde
ich will jetzt einfach mal anfangen zu
labern ich hoffe ich schaffe das so in
einem sonntag man sehen
ja auf jeden fall ich habe irgendwie
keinen plan also leute ich glaube ich
mache jetzt schon so weiß ich zwei jahre
aktiv diese videos habe früher mal
angefangen habe hat mit 14 glaube ich
angefangen mit irgendeinem schrott der
mg oder wenn ich das heute sehe denke
ich warum hast du das gemacht aber ich
habe heute eine frage weil die wirklich
krass bock drauf hat und weil es mir
heftig spaß gemacht hat weiß ich nicht
aber dieser gedanke so glaubt übrigens
nicht wirklich gut mit an kartell ist
ist schon ja wie gesagt ein uhr sa so
und ich bin müde dass ist ein bisschen
schwer dann irgendwie merkel gerade auf
jeden fall dieser gedanke daran jo du
machst einfach ein video zeigt dass
menschen und baust durch deine eigene
persönlichkeit so eine community auf sag
ich mal und das hat damals mit
angefangen und habe ihn wirklich so spaß
daran und ich will nicht sagen dass ich
jetzt keinen spaß habe ich habe immer
noch heftig doch meistens wirklich
meistens daran ein video für euch zu
produzieren allerdings ist es auch ab
und zu mal so dass ich mir denke dass
sie mir denke dass ich mir denke ja
heute ist's schon mittwoch morgens
wieder donnerstag das heißt du musst was
raushauen damit dein weg halt weiter
nach oben geht sage ich mal
jetzt habe ich gerade wieder so einen
hänger irgendwie drin keine ahnung
doch sein wollte auf jeden fall ich habe
jetzt 270.000 abonnenten wie schon eben
gesagt das ist eine heftige zeit für
mich die niemals für möglichkeiten habe
allerdings ist es jetzt halt so
wahnsinnig alltag geworden das halt so
viele menschen gibt die sich halt ab und
zu gucken dass du kommentare bist dass
du oft gesagt bekommst du bist cool und
so klar noch nicht bekommen doch hier du
bist ein bastard aber eigentlich nur
sehr selten
das ist halt so eine art routine so die
man mit der man halt täglich
konfrontiert wird konfrontiert habe ich
das gedreht ich glaube schon
und in letzter zeit sind auch wieder so
viele menschen neu dazugekommen ich
glaube ich hab jetzt in 30 tagen
wirklich wieder 45.000 abonnenten
gemacht was weiß ich nicht dass es
heftig jetzt machen wir einen kleinen
umweg so ich habe jetzt halt mein abi
hab ich auch schon glaube ich oft gesagt
und was ich danach mache weiß ich
überhaupt nicht so das einzige was jetzt
wirklich so fest habt ist diese
reichweite auf youtube und dann mein abi
was ich damit sagen will so youtube ist
etwas richtig cooles aber es ist nichts
festes und es gibt wirklich so diese art
unterliegt man so im bett und denke ich
so jo stell dir vor youtube läuft jetzt
einfach nicht mehr weil an dem tag gab
es halt wieder so ein einbruch sei das
hat sich vielleicht total bescheuert an
aber es gibt wirklich so die tage da
mache ich so richtig geil clixoom voll
gut abonnenten
was mich wirklich so das erstaunt mich
selber von mir dass ich wirklich jetzt
denke was mir früher wirklich nur um den
spaß ging aber jetzt geht es einem
wirklich so da kann mir auch keiner was
vormachen der ähnliche reichweite hat
wie ich oder so das sagen ja auch so
viele gute kollegen von mir die auch so
youtube videos machen wie ich und auch
relativ viele menschen haben wie das
gucken das ist wirklich nicht mehr um
den spaß geht oder was heißt um den spaß
es geht uns allen natürlich noch ich
würd's nicht machen wenn ich überhaupt
keinen bock mehr dran hätte aber man
kann auf jeden fall nicht mehr sagen es
geht mir nur noch um spaß sondern es
geht mir persönlich auch mittlerweile
weiß wie ich bin unterhalten mensch so
geht's halt wirklich oder oder so ich
sag mal so langfristigen erfolg zu haben
macht mich schon in gewisser weise so
glücklich dass man für die arbeit die
man macht auch geschätzt wird und
dadurch erfolg hat würde ich jetzt hier
keinen erfolg haben würde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr machen das
jetzt vielleicht hat für euch
aber das kann ich einfach mal so offen
sagen es gibt für mich so viele dinge
die sind mir viel wichtiger als youtube
aber ich kann schon sagen dass mich
youtube in gewisser weise bzw
der spaß an youtube und auch der erfolg
der gehört weiß nicht dass das hört sich
vielleicht das ist hier schon zehnmal es
hört sich komisch an aber so youtube
alter ich wäre coole freunde zu haben in
der schule gute noten zu schreiben weil
sie nicht eine coole familie zu haben
also was das in sachen die mich so
glücklich machen aber seitdem ich mit
youtube angefangen habe und vor allem
jetzt so seit dem letzten jahren meist
halt immer weiter in die höhe ging
kann ich auch sagen dass das ist
wahrscheinlich nur durch youtube
bekommen aber erfolg ist auch eine sache
die mich glücklich machen ich weiß
letztlich ein paar von euch werden das
jetzt wahrscheinlich so aufpassen als
wäre ich so erfolgreich oder so keine
ahnung das ist auch nicht so aber es
gehört für mich einfach dazu und
deswegen denke ich manchmal so nach soja
heute lief youtube nicht gut wird es
jetzt so weiter gehen und irgendwann
einbrechen und dann hast du was ich
damit meine vielleicht mal ein schönes
beispiel ich habe jetzt glaube ich in 30
tagen
jetzt kommen wir irgendwelche zahlen und
so habe ich so und so viele klicks
gemacht ich glaube 35 millionen oder
vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr kann
ich euch nicht genau sagen was wirklich
heftig ist das ist normal dass wenn ich
mir das vorstelle junge sei stolz ich
bin auch heftig stolz darauf aber sei
einfach mit dir selber zufrieden du hast
schon einiges erreicht und wenn es nicht
so läuft weiterhin dann ist es halt so
allerdings denken wir mal du willst das
einfach und du willst noch weiter
vorankommen du willst noch viel größer
werden und youtube ist einfach das was
du schon lange machst was zu deinem
leben dazugehört und damit kannst du
nicht auf und sondern du willst wirklich
ganz nach oben so oder auch generell es
gibt immer so phasen bei mir da läuft
halt wirklich nicht so gut wie sonst es
läuft immer noch heftig gut zum
vergleich zu früher wo es unnormal gut
aber man ist halt wirklich so wehrmann
ich sag mal so lang da ließ wirklich gut
und 100 später läuft zeit nicht gut da
denkt man sich so vorstellen die vorerst
läuft jetzt die ganze zeit nicht gut
auch wenn es ein total dummer gedanke
ist eigentlich total unrealistisch ist
ich denke mir das halt trotzdem oft und
da bin ich auch nicht alleine dass ich
hab halt wie gesagt mit vielen youtube
kollegen auch schon drüber
wochen bei denen ist halt genau so und
das ist wirklich so eine sache die habe
ich halt nur durch youtube und da denkt
man viel darüber nach und manchmal auch
ein bisschen zu viel auch wenn es total
dumm ist eigentlich weil es gar nicht
sehen können aber es ist halt wirklich
so eine sache klar es geht noch richtig
viel um den spaß aber es ist auch ein
normaler druck so auf einem wenn man
halt wirklich so weist das gucken viele
leute die erwarten was von mir und du
musst was bringen und es muss einfach
laufen so versteht ihr je weiß jetzt
nicht ob ich mich da so verstehen könnt
ich hoffe es ihr könnt sie in die
kommentare schreiben
allerdings glaube ich auch dass es für
mich persönlich ziemlich wichtig ist
dass ich diese eigenschaft habe bzw für
youtuber die diese eigenschaft haben
oder bei leuten die generell versuchen
irgendwas zu erreichen da finde ich
glaube ich ist diese eigenschaften die
ich jetzt auch habe bzw
ja wirklich dieser gedankengang ist
wichtig weil wenn du den ich hasse ich
glaube dass es so wirklich dieser
ansporn der mich dazu treibt jetzt auch
durchzuziehen und keine ahnung mich
darauf zu konzentrieren und einfach zu
machen worauf ich bock habt und wenn es
halt nicht so gut läuft denkt man
darüber nach und versucht noch besser
versucht noch bessere ich kriege es gar
nicht auf die kette auf jeden fall
versucht man dadurch noch besseren
content zu liefern
noch mehr zu schaffen also was es ist
ein heftiger druck aber das gehört halt
dazu im obi und damit lebe ich jetzt
schon etwas länger und ich bin heftig
froh wenn es gut läuft wenn es nicht so
gut läuft ist es halt so und dadurch
versucht man halt noch besser zu werden
und das wollte ich euch mal so sagen es
ist halt youtube ist nicht so immer für
die leute die halten reichweite haben so
da denkt man sich ja auch bei denen das
ist doch cool so reinke zu haben aber
ich bin froh dass ich es halt gemacht
habe und durch youtube mir schon so viel
ermöglicht es ist auf jeden fall der
spaß aber es sind auch ganz viele andere
dinge drumherum dem ich jetzt dazu
bringen weiter zu machen genau das
wollte ich mal sagen wenn euch das video
gefeiert würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr dann nach oben gibt wenn ihr öfter
mal so was von mir hören wollt so
realistisch oder so können
ansonsten noch meine erinnerung kommt
jetzt wirklich fast täglichen video da
ich jetzt mich voll darauf konzentrieren
kann ja ich kann sagen wie ich versuche
umzusetzen bzw
keine ahnung ich will das wirklich
einfach ich will auf youtube ganz nach
oben kommen und mal sehen wie weit ich
schaffen wäre da bin ich selber auch
heftig gespannt was die zukunft bringt
mit euch halmich frau jetzt heftig dass
ihr mich in so einer großen anzahl schon
jetzt hier verfolgte jetzt schlafen und
noch einen schönen tag noch mal kurz
erinnerung jetzt kommt jetzt wirklich
oft was fast täglich oder so keine
ahnung habe ich auch ein bisschen
verplant hat drei leute wir sehen uns
dann schon morgen wieder
und ja hieß